♪
>> Jesse: HE IS THE
$6 TRILLION MAN.
BIG GOVERNMENT JOE BIDEN IS
PROMISING AN AVALANCHE OF NEW
SPENDING ON TOP OF HIS MASSIVE
STIMULUS PLAN.
BIDEN WANTS TO EXPAND THE ROLL
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
JUST ABOUT EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR
LIFE.
>> MY AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN
GUARANTEES FOR TWO ADDITIONAL
YEARS OF PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
EVERY PERSON IN AMERICA.
UNIVERSAL HIGH-QUALITY PRESCHOOL
FOR THREE AND 4-YEAR-OLDS.
NOT DAY CARE, PRESCHOOL.
WE CAN'T STOP THERE.
GOING TO ADD TWO YEARS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ON TOP OF
THAT.
THE AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN IS
GOING TO PROVIDE UP TO 12 WEEKS
OF PAID FAMILY AND MEDICAL
LEAVE.
PLAN ON GIVING TAX BREAKS TO THE
WORKING CLASS FOLKS ARE MAKING
EVERYBODY PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
>> Jesse: JUAN, HERE'S WHY
REPUBLICANS ARE SO SUSPICIOUS OF
DEMOCRATS PUSHING SOCIALISM.
REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONLY THING
STANDING IN THE WAY OF DEMOCRATS
AND SOCIALISM.
EVERY TIME YOU GUYS GET POWER,
YOU ADD THE NEW PROGRAM, GIVE
MORE FREE STUFF AND IT NEVER
ENDS.
>> Juan: WOW.
I HAVE THE OTHER VIEW.
I'M A MEMBER THAT THE ECONOMY
ABSOLUTELY TOOK OFF UNDER
BILL CLINTON FOR EXAMPLE.
I REMEMBER THAT WHEN BARACK
OBAMA GOT INCOME HE HAD TO
RESCUE THE ECONOMY.
IDLE THINK THERE'S ANY QUESTION
ABOUT THAT AND I THINK THAT THE
ECONOMY EXPERIENCED TREMENDOUS,
CONSISTENT GROWTH UNDER OBAMA,
NOT AS FAST AS I KNOW YOU
WOULD'VE LIKED BUT IT WAS
CONSISTENT.
I THINK RIGHT NOW WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THIS BIDEN PROGRAM AS
SOCIALIST, I THINK I'VE SAID
THIS SEVERAL TIMES SO PARDON ME
FOR REPEATING IT.
BUT SINCE JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED
ON THIS AGENDA, THE STOCK MARKET
IS UP 20%.
THAT MEANS THE INVESTOR CLASS,
THE CEOs, THE BANKERS, AS WELL
AS THE UNIONS AND WORKERS ALL
SAY THIS IS A GOOD PLAN.
WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT.
THE STOCK MARKET SAYS LET'S GO,
BABY.
THE GDP SAYS LET'S TAKE OFF.
SPECIFICS OF THE PLAN, THINGS
LIKE UNIVERSAL PRE-K, THINGS
THAT MEAN SOMETHING TO ME, PAID
LEAVE, AND SHOULD MEAN SOMETHING
TO YOU.
YOU JUST HAD A BABY.
YOU GOT A WEEK OFF.
WE HAVE PAID LEAVE.
JOE BIDEN SAYS THAT IN APRIL
WORKERS STATEMENT IT SHOULDN'T
JUST BE FOR PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND
ME.
IT SHOULD BE FOR HOURLY WORKERS
AS WELL.
THAT'S GOOD FOR THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
IT'S TRUE IN OTHER DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES.
WHY NOT HERE?
>> Jesse: OUR SUPPORT PAID
LEAVE FOR YOU TOO, JUAN.
>> Juan: I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Jesse: WHEN I WAS GETTING
AT IS REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONLY
ONES PUMPING THE BRAKES HERE ON
DEMOCRATS EXPANDING GOVERNMENT.
EVERY TIME THEY GET POWER, THEY
WANT TO JUST SPEND MORE AND GROW
THE GOVERNMENT MORE AND MORE AND
MORE.
WE ARE THE ONLY ONE STOPPING
THEM.
IF WE WEREN'T HERE, IT WOULD
JUST BE A FULL SOCIALIST
TAKEOVER.
>> Dana: I THINK THIS IS A
MORE USEFUL DIRECTION THAT THIS
CONVERSATION IS GOING, BEYOND
JUST THE EYE-POPPING NUMBERS HE
WANTS TO SPEND.
IT IS, HOW DOES HE WANT TO SPEND
IT?
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT SHIFT OF
HAVING GOVERNMENTS BEING CONTROL
OF EVEN MORE THINGS.
HOW IS IT WORKED OUT IN THE
PAST?
LOOK AT EUROPE IN TERMS OF
INNOVATION AND ECONOMIC GROWTH.
ONE OF THE REASONS THEIR
MILITARIES ARE SO BASICALLY WEAK
AND HUMBLED IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ALL THESE ENTITLEMENTS THAT THET
SPENDING NEVER STOPS.
IT'S ALSO A PROBLEM HERE.
THE REST OF OUR BUDGET GETS
SQUEEZED BECAUSE WE NEVER WANT
TO DEAL WITH THOSE PROGRAMS LIKE
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE AND
THAT'S TRUE OF BOTH PARTIES.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS I
THINK JOE BIDEN'S AGENDA IS
ALREADY STALLING OUT AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHY I THINK THAT.
HE WENT ON A BIG TRIP YESTERDAY
TO VIRGINIA.
HE WAS TRYING TO SELL HIS
AMERICAN JOBS PLAN.
NOT A BLIP.
YOU ALREADY HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO
ARE IN TOUGH RACES IN 2022
SAYING, YEAH, I DON'T THINK WE
ARE GOING TO BE FOR THAT.
OR THE VERY SMALL MARGINS THEY
HAVE, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MUSCLE THIS THROUGH.
THE LONGER IT HANGS OUT THERE
AND GETS MORE SCRUTINY LIKE WHAT
WE ARE DOING RIGHT NOW, THE MORE
LIKELY IT IS THAT IT SORT OF
DIES ON THE VINE OR AT LEAST
GETS PARAGUAY WAY BACK.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THAT'S
TRUE, KATIE?
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE SCARED TO
GO ALONG WITH JOE'S PLAN BECAUSE
THEY ARE GOING TO GET SHELLACKED
NEXT ELECTION?
>> Katie: IF THE SENATE WERE
MORE HEAVILY DEMOCRAT, NOT
50/50.
AND JOE MANCHIN AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA DIDN'T HAVE AS
MUCH POWER AS THEY DO THAT THEY
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO PUSH
THROUGH A LOT OF THESE THINGS.
I THINK IT'S MORE OF A SENATE
ISSUE AND IT WOULD BE IN THE
HOUSE.
BUT ON THIS ISSUE --
WHOSE PHONE IS RINGING?
>> Juan: IT WAS MINE.
I APOLOGIZE.
>> Jesse: IT WAS JUAN.
IT WAS JUAN.
>> Katie: IT'S OKAY.
ON THIS ISSUE OF THE FREE
COLLEGE, COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
JOE BIDEN IS PUSHING THIS AT THE
SAME TIME YOU HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SAYING NO MORE ADVANCED MATH.
FREE COLLEGE BUT YOU DON'T GET
TO ACTUALLY TAKE ADVANCED
COURSES THAT MAY GET YOU TO
COLLEGE OR GET YOU A SCHOLARSHIP
TO COLLEGE.
THE OTHER THING IS, THE CRADLE
THE CRADLE TO GRAVE SOCIALISM,
THIS IS ALWAYS SOLD AS AMERICANS
HAVING MORE OPPORTUNITY.
PAID LEAVE WILL GIVE MORE WOMEN
MORE OPPORTUNITY.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE.
IT MEANS YOU HAVE LESS FREEDOM,
ZERO CHOICES IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR GETS COMPLETELY
SUFFOCATED BECAUSE IT CAN'T
AFFORD THESE POLICIES.
WE ARE SEEING IT RIGHT NOW WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
RESTAURANTS CAN'T HIRE ENOUGH
PEOPLE BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T
GOING BACK TO WORK BECAUSE THEY
ARE MAKING MORE MONEY FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEY ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO WORK AND SO THE
OPPOSITE OF THESE PROGRAMS IS
ALWAYS THE TRUTH.
LESS FREEDOM, FEWER CHOICES,
MORE EXPENSES THAN BEING SOLD BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: LAST WORD TO
GREG GUTFELD.
>> Greg: TO POINT OUT THAT THE
GDP AND STOCKS AREN'T REACTING
TO JOE'S TAX PLAN.
THEY ARE REACTING TO THE
PANDEMIC SHUTDOWN THAT'S
REOPENING.
THIS IS ETERNALLY TRUE, YOU
ALWAYS GET BIG GAINS IN AN
ECONOMY, GDP AND STOCK MARKET
AFTER HUGE LOSSES BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A LOT OF TURF TO EXPAND,
GROW INTO IT LEVELS OFF AND THEN
THE GROWTH GETS SMALLER AND
SMALLER AND SMALLER.
YES, I AM AN ECONOMIST.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
DEBATE, IT'S NOT THE 1980s
ANYMORE.
IF YOU CALL SOMETHING SOCIALISM,
IT'S NOT GOING TO PERSUADE A
POPULATION THAT HAS NO IDEA WHAT
IT MEANS.
NO ONE IS BEING EDUCATED ANYMORE
ABOUT SOCIALISM.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
USSR.
THEY HAVEN'T READ HISTORY BOOKS.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
CRADLE TO GRAVE GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD.
WOW, THAT'S AWESOME.
THAT MEANS THE GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO BE WITH ME UNTIL I DIE.
I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
ANYTHING.
THE THING IS, THE REASON WHY
THEY THINK THAT WAY AND IT'S
NATURAL BECAUSE NO ONE HAS
EXPLAINED TO THEM SO DISTINCTLY
THE TRADE-OFF.
OBVIOUSLY THIS COMES WITH A
PRICE.
YOU NEED TO TELL THEM IF YOU
TURN EVERYTHING OVER TO
GOVERNMENT, YOU CAN AFFORD IT.
THE COUNTRY GOES BROKE.
AND WHEN THERE IS A WAR, YOUR
MILITARY WILL BE HOG-TIED.
GOODS AND SERVICES WILL NOT MEET
THE STANDARDS OF PRIVATE
INDUSTRY.
WHAT YOU PAY FOR, I.E. AMTRAK OR
THE MAIL, IT'S NOTHING LIKE WHAT
FEDEX CAN DO.
IT GOES TO HELL IN TERMS OF
QUALITY.
THE INDIVIDUAL IS LESS INCLINED
TO ACHIEVE GREATNESS IF THEY
DON'T HAVE TO.
THEY ARE STILL GOING TO GET A
FREE MEAL AND A FREE X AND FREE
Y AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORK SO
HARD AND LASTLY YOU JUST RUN OUT
OF RICH PEOPLE.
EITHER THEY GO BROKER THEY
LEAVE.
WE NEED TO EXPLAIN.
>> Jesse: OR YOU CAN JUST SAY
THE TAX AND SPENDING LIBERALS
ARE RACIS